hello Internet welcome to film theory in
the third and final episode of our short
little foray and investigative
journalism thanks for sticking with it I
know that this one was a bit of a
departure for the channel but honestly
this was a personal passion project for
me after watching Shane's series on Jake
there were three main topics that I
wanted to address first as a creator on
this platform for a huge chunk of my
life I wanted to explore the ulterior
motives behind this new generation of
youtubers and the way that they and the
corporation's oftentimes funding them
can be exploiting audience trust second
as a father and advocate for child
education I wanted to raise awareness of
the manipulation inherent in advertising
to kids and why it's so easy to do
whether it was intentional or not and
lastly we come to today's episode where
as a viewer I wanted to take a step back
and cover Shane's trend of docu-series
in general to raise awareness to him and
more importantly to you about the
dangerous tactics that storytellers can
use to sway your opinions about the
characters and their stories now as I've
done these last few episodes I've seen a
lot of comments from you all watching
that reflected a lot of my own feelings
when I was watching Shane series on Jake
for the first time
I kinda wish Shane didn't hold back it
was too empathetic I loved Shane but
sometimes his videos in this category
aren't always revealing the entire truth
for that he's not going as in-depth as
he could up when seeking the truth he
promoted this thing as nothing is off
the table it was clear that some things
were off the table I personally wanted
to see Jake Paul answer for things like
his business decisions and his merch but
instead it all just felt like one big
Redemption arc for him which raises the
question should Shane have covered all
that business stuff does it matter that
he didn't and most importantly are his
docu-series actually dangerous because
of the way he portrays the people in um
almost as soon as the Jake Paul
documentary started airing Shane came
under fire for giving Jake a platform
and then for cranking up the drama on
his story by comparing him to sociopaths
and then by playing dramatic music and
using editing tricks to emphasize
specific moments and finally for making
excuses for Jake's bad behavior by
shifting blame to his parents and his
brother
so was the internet right to be
levelling criticisms at change today
we're gonna find out Oh
when in case you were sick of the guy
this theory isn't about Jake anymore no
this time the whole Bank of shan dazu
memories are under my theoretical
microscope oh I'm nervous you probably
should be or maybe not the only way to
find out is to dive in the first and
perhaps biggest complaint that Shane got
in his coverage of Jake Paul was his use
of music to overemphasize certain key
moments early on in the series Jade Paul
might be a sociopath he has a creepy dad
it felt to many viewers disingenuous
manipulative and in response it's
something that chained held back on as
the series went on but even shots like
this the final one of the series in
slow-mo with somber piano music playing
underneath is manipulative turning a
simple walk away from the camera into
something much more a deep meaningful
reflective moment where Jake's fake
persona is finally dropped a moment that
screams this this right here is the real
Jake Paul when seriously he was just
walking away from the camera all of
these things the war stings the glitches
slow-mo shots and sad music are all
examples of the psychological principle
known as priming just like you coat a
wall with primer before laying down the
paint so that the paint goes on smoother
you primed the audience so that they
more easily accept what you're trying to
convince them of you know how you
recognize that there's about to be a
jump-scare in a horror movie because
you're entering a scary place and then a
door starts creaking open and music
changes that's a form of priming but
it's not all about just music and
editing everyone has made the joke that
it takes a long time for a shame
docu-series to get started all that time
that Shane spends talking about how
nervous he is and generally spending a
lot of time self-deprecating in both
this series and in the Jeffrey star
series but why why is he so nervous no
one talks about this but Shane has a
massive youtube presence he's one of the
longest standing and best loved creators
on the platform he doesn't need to be
nervous with anyone and yet he portrays
himself as being insecure in front of
his subjects well whether he means it or
not he's priming his audience to feel
the same way he does like he's entering
the presence of someone much greater if
Shane Dawson approaches Geoffrey star or
Jake Paul like a guy who looks up to him
or just wants to impress him well it
Prime's us as the audience to also think
that those people are worthy of those
emotions his anticipation becomes our
anticipation
he's the audience stand-in when what
we're really seeing is just one massive
online celebrity talking to yet another
massive online celebrity
I mean seriously Shane you've been a
YouTube
for over a decade have a house in a
really upscale part of Los Angeles
you're a bigger deal than a bunch of
your documentary subjects I mean sure
you might buy sure it's a target but
that's because target just sells really
good shirts anyway both Shane and Jake
also use lamb shading a lot throughout
the series to get you thinking the way
that they want you to be thinking
basically lamb shading is the technique
of levelling criticism against yourself
instead of waiting for people to use
those criticisms against you in the case
of the Jake Paul docu-series video one
is dedicated to Shane acknowledging
upfront that people will hate him for
doing the videos that they'll
unsubscribe that they'll accuse him of
giving Jake a platform Shane if you do
this I literally will stop watching
Shane Dawson if he's gonna try to sit
here and make me feel bad for Jake Paul
and sure some people did all of those
things but because Shane lamb shaded us
with those arguments they immediately
lost most of the power that they would
have had if they had just come out of
the blue jake paul also lampshades and
his opening call to Shane saying that
people hate him and that Shane will
regret doing this people hate me I don't
it's like this is gonna hurt you then
and like I don't acknowledge in his own
flaws or at least that other people say
that he has flaws which in turn deprives
the haters of all of their ammo I mean I
myself lampshade all the time on the
show I lampshade that my jokes are bad
because they are all the time it's time
for your interview how about it's time
to not have a cringy intro joke at the
expense of markiplier personalities oh
and what that enables me to do is defuse
all comments about my cringy humour even
me lamp shading about my own lamp
shading is in and of itself lamp shading
you can't hold it against me if I
acknowledge it move on so let's move on
and then finally there's framing framing
is essentially how something is
presented to the audience that
influences the choices that people make
about how to process that information
the biggest piece of framing and Shane
series is the entire discussion of
sociopaths at the very beginning of the
series just by asking the question or
Jake and Logan sociopaths it frames
every interaction and video clip that
happens afterward in a way that makes
you think maybe they are so see
paths by saying this and where I
realized and research and the more I
learned of a sociopath and then showing
this where Logan goes from pretending to
be nervous to not suddenly it's no
longer simply just someone putting on a
show for the camera but rather it's
implicitly saying wow this person must
have a facade a lack of emotion it must
be evidence of sociopathy mentioning the
word sociopath and using this treatment
is a lot different than using this
treatment again let me lamp [ __ ] here I
know this because I do it all the time
this kind of framing happens over and
over along with priming to paint a
picture of people who can't speak for
themselves before seeing any footage of
Jake's dad were prefaced with the fact
that Shane and his team have heard that
he's weird I've heard things about yeah
okay sure
he's definitely weird but Shane sets us
up to already have these preconceived
notions about characters around Jake
Paul based on the way that he himself
has talked about them in advance
one of the biggest framing decisions
that any filmmaker has is how to end his
movie Shane could have ended his
docu-series in any way that he wanted
like say with Jake's ex-girlfriend
Alyssa violet a moment that as I
understand it chronologically seemed to
be one of the last things that he shot
that would leave a very different
impression on the overall narrative arc
of the story than ending on that slow-mo
sad piano shot and sure that's a big
decision but even the smallest of things
are subject to framing look at this
Shane late-night kitchen ripped pajamas
getting himself a diet coke excellent
choice a drink by the way this shot
seems like it does nothing but in
reality why it's there is because it's
framing what comes next update and also
a disclaimer and also an apology it
rolls directly into him addressing the
early criticisms of the audience leveled
against the first parts of the series
this scene makes him sympathetic
downtrodden and relatable he's been up
all night
he drinks Diet Coke and has ripped
pajamas just like us this apology would
look and feel very differently if it was
framed like say in the vestibule of your
mansion with your Jeep out for
I think that's what my and many other
viewers biggest issue was with Shane's
docu-series that it was meant to be an
honest tell-all about this controversial
figure I want to really be honest about
it and investigate you but in the end it
came off as biased in Jake's favor and
honestly that makes sense right
controversial figures aren't gonna just
agree to do expose videos on themselves
to get the level of access that Shane
does the subject matter of the videos
needs to be confident that the story
being told is gonna favor them but that
just wasn't how this thing was branded
and it wasn't just this one on Jay Paul
either
how can he do an honest assessment of
the hot mess that was Tanic on searching
for a person to pin the blame on went
animaux Jo herself who created the
ill-fated event in the first place was
the one who accepted your Streamy award
in your absence
accepting the Streamy on his behalf is
Tana modo Gabi Hanna's reaction right
there yeah hashtag relatable it was mine
to the person who ripped off her fans
and made them wait outside for multiple
days and then got exposed by Shane she's
the one who's gonna accept his award
it's an odd choice I think we all can
agree this is the only time I'll ever be
holding a creator of the Year award to
be real here you guys I wouldn't even be
doing anything if it wasn't machine and
then Shane tweets about her being family
I'm like way too nice way too forgiving
way too loyal
can't do that Shane you're a
documentarian we need you to expose the
unbiased truths you are the arbiter of
these facts is what I thought but in
researching this episode I learned that
I was wrong and I couldn't have been any
more wrong wrong wrong
wrong wrong when I and I'm sure a lot of
you think about the term documentary I
think we all have a pretty clear image
in our head of antelope running from
Lions in Africa or a trip through the
cosmos or an informational doc about
people like jiro Dreams of Sushi or exit
through the gift shop all narrated by
Morgan Freeman I'm Morgan Freeman cuz it
is always Morgan Freeman yeah all
travelers on an unending voyage of
discovery documentaries are the things
my parents used to watch on the History
Channel and now Shane Dawson is doing a
cool new take on them by using YouTube
vlog style with investigative journalism
but here's the thing documentaries
weren't what you thought they were there
are a few really famous places that you
can go to show off your documentary film
skills like the can or Sundance Film
Festival's both of them have entry
definitions for their documentary film
divisions that essentially boil down to
the following five components one the
use of artful film language and the
ability to connect with an audience to
the use of effective storytelling three
originality for cultural relevance and
finally they have to inspire the
audience to want to know more about
their subject and that's it that's
really the list four criteria for a
documentary film do you notice anything
missing right away there is nothing that
says that documentaries have to be
truthful I mean sure it has to meet the
dictionary definition of a documentary
which is a film about a real person or
event but there's nothing in these
criteria about having to tell the whole
story or portray your subject in a
balanced
wait all you have to do is talk about
them documentaries are about being
effective storytellers not about being
effective journalists according to bill
Nichols who's one of the world's top
documentary scholars and theorists I'm
not making up his title is a genuine
film theorist the purpose of a
documentary isn't to educate you it's to
persuade you Nikol states that quote
documentary films mount an effort to
convince persuade or predispose us to a
particular view of the world it may
Entertainer please but it does so in
relation to rhetoric or persuasive
effort aimed at the existing social
world
end quote all those documentaries about
penguins on melting polar icecaps what
they're really doing is trying to
persuade us to stop global warming
those Neil deGrasse Tyson astronomy
documentaries fund Space Research jiro
Dreams of Sushi heat more Zushi and from
the looks of it Schoen meets all of
these criteria to the Tanit on expose a
place blame and get attendees a refund
interviewing jeffree star change the
audience's minds about someone who had
been branded a racist and dumb beauty
influencer investigating Jake Paul it's
a bit unclear but it ended up being
rehabilitating his image and
differentiating him from Logan shames
got himself three documentaries on his
hands just not documentaries in the way
that I and I think a lot of his audience
understood them it's interesting when
you step back and look at this whole
series this whole three part series have
done on film theory it all boils down to
one core theme manipulation through the
medium in episodes 1 & 2 I gave Jake a
really hard time because he and his
corporate backers are exploiting the
inherent trust that comes from the
medium of digital video YouTube is
different than movies and TV at least
for now viewers expect more authenticity
from it because it is literally people
holding a camera to their face on
YouTube there's a perceived truthfulness
that can lead people to believe creators
don't have their own agenda when we've
seen in the case of people like Jake
that they most certainly do
the same can be said of shame to a much
different extent we've just spent
however many minutes long this video
ends up being talking about how Shane's
just produced a textbook documentary
using persuasive techniques like framing
and priming that any good storyteller
uses there is absolutely nothing wrong
with it except for the runtime because
seriously buddy just make some tough
editing choices and trim down the whole
thing for crying out loud no the problem
is with us the viewer if it's surprising
to you to learn that documentaries are
manipulative and biased like it was
honestly for me then the problem is you
and me we expect our documentarians to
be honest but they're not and according
to their medium they don't have to be so
what makes them dangerous isn't the way
they're presented it's the way that we
watch them we expect the medium of
documentaries to be truthful there is no
requirement for that whatsoever we watch
YouTube and documentaries like we're
watching something that's absolutely
true when that couldn't be further from
reality I know you probably thought this
episode was gonna end with me bashing
Shane because I often times frame the
episodes that way but the truth is what
he's doing is smart
not just from a YouTube programming
perspective but from a cultural
relevancy standpoint the real takeaway
from this episode in this whole Jake
Paul series set of theories docu theory
oh I like that is this don't accept
everything you see as fact and don't
expect people on YouTube to be truthful
or unbiased even your absolutely
favorite creators I can tell you that
most of us try to be as honest as
possible when we're making videos
everyone everyone has some kind of
agenda and critical thinking is the only
thing that stands between you and being
taken in don't be someone who passively
accepts what you're told whether it's to
buy tickets to a 19 year olds YouTube
convention or buying a t-shirt from
someone who's dabbing on their haters if
you think about it or you don't have to
think about I'm just gonna explicitly
tell you this whole issue is the entire
reason that film theory and game theory
exists
channels I learned early on to think
critically about the stories I'm being
told the underlying motivations that
exist for why people might be telling me
those stories and that led me to do
shows that look at things from a
different angle that asks the question
maybe they're lying to us if I can pull
back the curtain and inspire critical
thinking and some of you who watch to
encouraging you to keep on asking
questions well then I'm doing my job
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and back to normal stuff later
this week cuz I know a lot of you people
are like where are the actual films and
the actual theories oh but lastly for
God's sake Shane don't make the next one
a 13-part series though if you're
looking for some good expose material
I've seen you tweeting a lot about
defies MCN closing as someone who was a
defi employee and was in their network
when the company collapsed and has
worked in a lot of different capacities
across the multi-channel network
universe I have plenty of fun stories to
tell you
[Music]
you